bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
du razer phone je suis aussi es il ya le
stand razer razer désolé pour mon accent
qui juste derrière j'ai vu tourner le
téléphone je les prix entre les mains je
les utilise et je puis vous assurer que
c'est vraiment une bête de poutès
[Musique]
c'est pas juste une rumeur à zoss
vraiment des produits pour les gamer qui
est extraordinaire et on peut dire que
ce téléphone
dauphin du spécification est vraiment
aussi les autres alors très clairement
c'est un produit qui est destiné aux
gamers
pourquoi parce qu'il est vraiment
optimisé pour les joueurs que ce soit le
taux de rafraîchissement que ce soit la
puissance c'est vraiment une machine qui
est fait pour les gens qui veulent jouer
qu'ils veulent de la fluidité et qui
veulent quelque chose d'hyper smooth
vous avez un taux de rafraîchissement
jusqu'à 120 hertz par seconde alors ça
vous parle peut-être pas mais pour les
jeux face à quatre pattes
vous avez quelque chose de hyper fluide
quel que soit le jeu vous pouvez bouger
vous pouvez naviguer c'est extrêmement
fluide c'est hyper aprécial nurun du sit
in ouvert les yeux et des oreilles
vous avez un écran quad hd les couleurs
sont présentes
les contrastes sont beaux l'écran
s'éteint 5,7 pouces 1440 par 2560 x m
c'est vraiment un très très joli produit
le son est complètement dingue
oui obtient trop trop bien sur le stand
de razer vous avez un son qui est
complètement ouf pourtant avec le son à
fond on entendait complètement le son
des haut-parleurs et le son est clair et
limpide
côté processeur vous avez un qualcomm
snapdragon 835 et 8 giga de mémoire vive
alors que notre suite à ces giga celui
ci a carrément 8 giga renvoi en termes
de processeurs en perte de vitesse tout
est fait pour aller vite avec un
excellent rafraîchissement on voit que
ce produit vraiment optimisé pour les
gens qui veut de la qualité qui vu de la
rapidité qui veulent pas s'embêter
pareil au niveau de la batterie vous
avez une batterie de 4000 méliand
perreur donc du temps de jeu donc un
produit qui devrait pas coûter
rapidement de plus il se recharge
extrêmement rapidement mis un quart
d'heure vous l'avez recharger à 60
mentions j'ai pas vu le temps de
recharge ça forcément il est câblé sur
le stand
je les crois sur parole mais c'est vrai
que le produit est vraiment bluffant
côté photo vous avez un double capteur à
l'arrière de 12 mégapixels vous avez le
grand candy ou vendre 7 et le zoom en
2.6 et l'appareil photo frontal c'est un
8 mégapixels qui ouvre à 2 le câble de
recharge c'est l'usbc 64 giga de
stockage que vous pouvez monter jusqu'à
2 tera là on parle pas des 256 gars
qu'on peut retrouver sur énormément de
smartphones là on parle carrément de
deux des rats donc en termes de stockage
si vous avez des choses qui sont
gourmandes pour pouvez y aller
d'encaisser à fond plus tôt soit un
androïde 7.1 nous gâte ce qui devrait
rapidement être bts ou un android 8.0
oreo on vend plus que la surcouche été
faite par razer est vraiment épuré
optimisé
leur environnement optimisé pour leurs
produits en plus ce qui est génial c'est
que vous pouvez complètement module est
plein de choses pourrait moduler la
cadence du processeur ou et moduler le
rafraîchissement de l'image pour pas
forcément consommé énormément et pour
s'adapter vraiment à tous les jeux vous
avez bien évidemment du wifi du
bluetooth 4 points 2 d'ailleurs pourquoi
pas de bluetooth 5.0 ça c'est la
question pour votre téléphone est une
machine de guerre
pourquoi cet arrêté au bout tous 4.2
allez savoir c'est intéressant plus
soldats ce conte une info au niveau de
la tête c'est du 0,302 et au niveau du
cor 530
c'est vrai que c'est un produit qui sera
pas fait pour tout le monde qui sera pas
adapté à tout le monde mais pour les
gens qui veulent vraiment du jeu pour
les passionnés pour ceux qui veulent de
la puissance pour ceux qui veulent un
téléphone qui s'inquiètent pas le razer
faune très clairement est fait pour vous
parce qu'il est d'une qualité
extraordinaire
dites moi ce que vous en pensez je sais
pas si vous vous et gamer si vous l'avez
déjà essayé je vous ai des produits
razer
mettez moi tout ça en commentaire je
suis curieux de voir ce petit sondage
est de savoir derrière l'écran qui joue
et qui joue pas ou alors si vous jouez
vous jouez à quoi merci beaucoup d'être
regardé cette vidéo vous avez bien
évidemment à laisser les jolies pousse à
vous abonner parce qu'on va encore
parler beaucoup plus de high tech et de
produits innovants
d'ici là soyez sages portez vous bien et
je vous embrasse
ciao